Democrats black police reform all
proclaiming the time to act is now the
creator of the 1619 project calls for
slavery reparations and the media focus
in on Koba 19 spikes in Texas in Florida
while ignoring California this is the
Ben Shapiro show well a lot to get to
today we're gonna get to everything co
vid related because we are seeing spikes
around the country only certain parts of
the country are apparently worth lots of
media attention like California which
actually may be seeing the biggest spike
by home county of LA County is now the
number one county in America in terms of
covered 19 identified infections that's
getting ignored in favor of Florida and
Texas we'll get to that in a little bit
we will also get to a new call for
slavery reparations which of course it's
not going to settle the problem because
the fact is that a lot of the people who
are calling for slavery reparations are
not going to suggest that once the
reparations have been made to people who
had an ancestor who 165 years ago is
being held in slavery that once that
reparation is made that suddenly the
problem has been fixed and now we can
move on with our lives none of that is
is the reality obviously we're gonna get
to the problems with slavery reparations
and the very very bad argument that's
being made by Nicole Hannah Jones which
of course is based and rooted in the
idea that America is endemically racist
continues to be endemically racist and
that nothing much has changed in the
United States we'll get to that in a
little bit first let's talk about the
reality of the markets the markets are
up and down right now there's so much
uncertainty in the markets and meanwhile
the government is just blowing out the
spending which means at some point
you're either gonna have to raise taxes
or they're gonna have to inflate the
currency all this would suggest you
might want to take a little bit of your
money and put it into precious metals
two weeks ago the Dow dropped 1,700
points in the opening hours because of
fear alone fear of coronavirus fear from
the Fed the gloomy outlook expected
spending of 10 trillion dollars to curb
the effects of kovat 19 diversify by 10
20 percent your portfolio put it in
precious metals Birch gold group can
help you right now text Ben's 47 47 47
when you purchase on or before July 31st
you get a free signed copy of my book
the right side of history Birch gold
will go to work for you make things
super simple text Ben to 47 47 47 right
now at least request a free information
kit on diversify and go and ask all your
questions they're the people I trust
with investing in precious metals
there's no obligation Birch gold group
has thousands
satisfied customers countless five-star
views an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau protect your family
today by protecting your savings like I
did by investing in gold with Birch gold
group sex been again - 47 47 47 during
the months of June or July when you open
an IRA in precious metals you get a
signed copy of my book the right side of
history for free again expand to 47 47
47 get all the information you need to
be a an informed investor in this
particular brand of investing get into
precious metals at least a little bit
you don't want to be reliant on the
volatility of a market that is bouncing
around like a yo-yo Birch gold at Tech
spends 47 47 47 for more information
okay so yesterday it became perfectly
obvious for those of us who were
unconvinced it has now been perfectly
obvious that what is going on right now
in the United States is not about
solutions
it's not about solutions it's not about
anything that is that is relevant to
solving the underlying problem it is not
about an attempt to breach gaps that
have existed in American life it is not
about an attempt to rectify historic
racism it's not even about an attempt to
stop police brutality it's not about
none of that
yesterday the Republicans brought up in
the Senate a police reform bill and the
police reform bill didn't give Democrats
everything they wanted for example it
did not outright ban chokeholds it said
that departments had to take a look at
chokeholds and decide how they would be
applied and the federal government would
make its funding contingent on a
particular procedures put in place with
regard to chokehold now they're a bunch
of Democrats who think the chokehold
should be outright ban because either
they are mischaracterizing what a
chokehold is there's a difference
between a chokehold and a and a
submission home or they're trying to
deprive law enforcement of a tool that
you sometimes require in order to make a
situation more quiescent as opposed to
being forced to use deadly force in a
case where somebody is resisting arrest
I mean this is really one of the
instances in which officers you see an
officer and the officer is trying to put
somebody into submission hold right
they're trying to they're trying to
deprive oxygen to the brain not the
person out or at least put the person in
a more quiet state the alternative to
that is the person continuing to thrash
around struggle maybe grab the officer's
gun what having Democrats really don't
know anything about police procedure
decide full-out on the federal level
exactly what local police departments
ought to do after a 30-year continuous
drop in crime in the United States is a
pretty astonishing move
Republicans were gonna do something
different they were gonna say okay these
chokeholds have sometimes resulted in
death
these submission holds and sometimes
resulted in death so we should look at
the procedures okay is a little bit
vague er Democrats didn't like that
okay so Democrats decided for that
reason among many others that they were
just going to block this police reform
bill put forward by the Republicans they
weren't even going to allow a vote on it
they weren't going to allow a vote now
just a couple weeks ago the idea was if
Republicans don't bring forward
legislation then they don't care about
black Americans so immediately
Republicans put together a bill senator
Tim Scott who's been very outspoken
about his belief that the police
sometimes do act in racially disparate
ways right he's talked about his own
personal experiences with what he
believes to be racial profiling he was
the lead sponsor on this bill when
Democrats rejected it outright now I
will note that the suggestion that
America is endemically plagued by racist
police is not backed by very much data
Jason Riley has a good piece in The Wall
Street Journal talking about how the
police act talking about the real
problem with police he points out in a
2015 Gallup poll taken after Michael
Brown was killed in Ferguson a majority
of black respondents had police treat
them fairly far more blacks 38% than
whites 18% said they want a greater
police presence in their local
communities another Gallup survey
published last year asked black and
Hispanic residents of low-income
neighborhoods about policing and found
these groups quote aren't averse to law
enforcement in fact they are
particularly concerned about crime in
their neighborhoods 59% both blacks and
Hispanics said they would like the
police to spend more time in their area
than they currently do making them more
likely than white residents 50 percent
to respond this way Democrats and
Republicans seem to agree them a more
uniform data collect data collection
among police agencies would be a good
thing says Jason Riley they're right but
it's no guarantee the media will report
the additional data or put it in context
we have plenty of data right now police
shootings have fallen precipitously
since the 1970s upward of 95 percent of
black homicides in the United States
don't involve law enforcement empirical
studies have found no racial bias in
police use of deadly force and the
racial disparities that do exist them
from racial differences in criminal
behavior the problem isn't a shortage of
data but a race-based narrative that is
immune to any data that challenge it
okay nonetheless there was a push for
police reform it is least across the
country our endemically brutal and
terrible and awful across the board and
so Republicans push for this bill and
then the Democrats block it the
Democrats
outright blocking 45 senators they don't
allow vote the Republicans controlled
the sentence the Republicans are gonna
get a majority here that 45 senators say
we're not even going to allow a vote
according to The Wall Street Journal a
minority of the Senate 45 Democrats
voted Wednesday to close off any debate
on a police reform bill not against the
bill against even allowing the Senate to
debate or offer amendments to Tim Scotts
proposal the Republicans were going to
allow something like 21 amendments to
the proposal a calculation is pure
election year cynicism block the Senate
from passing a bill that Republicans
could campaign on and denounce
Republicans for refusing to pass the
bill and House Democrats will pass this
week that would micromanage local police
departments blame Republicans for
opposing reform when Senate Democrats
were the real opponents is the Wall
Street Journal editorial board much of
the press corps will play along by
reporting on the house vote but treating
the Senate vote is a GOP failure the
election your calculation will largely I
mentioned as Democrats maneuver to
return the Senate to democratic party
control in 2821 it is no accident the
California Senator Kamala Harris led the
filibuster as she campaigned to be Joe
Biden's running mate so nothing gets
done which of course is the purpose
because the Republicans in the Senate
are not going to vote for the House bill
right they're not gonna vote for a bill
that micromanages the police to the
extent that Democrats want to
micromanage this thing so Democrats are
just demagogue you miss they don't
actually want 70% what they could have
is what Tim Scott points that he said
like you guys you could get 70 to 80% of
what you of what you want here and you
won't even allow us to to put up the
bill for amendment we can't even debate
this thing I get the feeling maybe you
have some different priorities here I
finally realized what the problem is mr.
president the actual problem is not what
is being offered it is who is offering
it and instead of getting 70 percent of
what you want it today and tomorrow and
next week you get zero and you're gonna
wait until the election to get more okay
well why wouldn't you take the 80% now
see if you can win the election and add
on the other 20% and the answer of
course is because they don't want the
80% now because they don't really want
to solve problems many of our
politicians many of the members of the
media class they don't wanna solve
problems they want to keep talking about
the problem because
politically beneficial for them they
they want to exaggerate the problem or
continue to jabber about the problem and
they want to make it look like people
who disagree with them on policy
actually don't care about the problem
leading that crew of course is Nancy
Pelosi was just a terrible human being I
mean really despicable she said over the
last 48 hours that Republicans are
trying to cover up George Floyd's murder
while they're trying to pass a police
reform bill that her colleagues are
blocking at her behest presumably she is
saying the Republicans are trying to
cover up
George Floyd's murder which is insane
insane have you seen a single Republican
defending Derek shavon like any of them
what the hell is she talking about but
of course it's all about the narrative
and the narrative is all about how
Republicans are a bunch of evil races
while Nancy Pelosi is of course a
godsend white wolf liberal here to save
black Americans across the board she was
asked about her ridiculous comments
yesterday on NBC News and she said no
I'm not gonna apologize for saying the
GOP covered up with Floyd's murder which
is nuts nuts Derrick shavon is going to
be tried by keith ellison in a
democratic state with a Democratic mayor
of Minneapolis with a Democratic AG when
you were speaking yesterday you said
that Republicans are quote trying to get
away with murder actually the murder of
George Floyd Senate Republicans are
demanding an apology for that statement
will you apologize absolutely positively
not the fact is people say I think you
frankly in the press have given them far
too much credit for a bill that does
nothing there's thing where you have
your bill they have their it's yeah our
bill does something theirs doesn't
matter their bill does nothing ours does
something therefore they're trying to
cover up the murder of George flame it's
despicable stuff by the way if you want
to talk about changing police behavior
in major cities it might be worthwhile
pointing out that every one of these
major cities is governed by a Democrat
every single one and you know what's
easier than passing federal police
reform having local mayors change police
procedures in democratic areas this
something Tim Scott points out as well I
said listen Democrats are talking we
need to change this we need to do
something guys you're in charge of these
cities we've seen riots in Ferguson you
seen riots in Baltimore Baltimore as a
Democrat city gives him riots in Atlanta
Democrat city seem riots in LA Democrat
City New York Democrat city like anytime
you want guys you can make this change
but I don't see you making the change I
just see a demagogue in the issue for
political gains as Republicans him Scott
and
joy Atlanta Minneapolis Los Angeles
Philadelphia all these cities could have
Bancho Coles themselves they could have
increased the police reporting
themselves they could have more data
information themselves they could have
de-escalation training themselves they
could have duty to intervene themselves
Minneapolis as well all these
communities have been run by Democrats
for decades yep yep so where are those
solutions
anytime bueller bueller maybe it wasn't
about the solutions maybe it was never
about the solutions maybe it was just
about promulgating the narrative that
all disparities in American life are due
to broad scale American racism then you
block the solution because if you
provide a solution then you can't talk
about how America's racist and evil
anymore you'll notice that every time
every time people talk about the evils
of American racism and they mentioned
police shootings they never ever mention
Walter Scott it is amazing you'll see
you will see them talk about how police
are wrongfully shooting black men then
you will see them list the names of the
victims and many of these cases are
cases that are really at the very least
tough right they'll mention the case of
Michael Brown Michael Brown was
justifiably shot by the police the
Department of Justice under Barack Obama
found that that was the case they will
mention the the the race card Brooks
case a case in which a black man
wrestled down two officers took a Taser
off one tased an officer tried to tase
the other one while running away and
then got shot don't mention that okay
that is a disputed fact pattern at the
very least to say that as a clear-cut
case of racist murder is insane and
completely disconnected from facts so
they'll talk about that one I'll talk
about Tamir rice which is a horrible
situation in which a twelve-year-old boy
was shot by the police after he was
going around in a park and he had a he
had a pellet gun he had a BB gun but he
had sawed off the front of the BB gun
the orange part normally when you buy a
BB gun there's an orange part on the
front that lets deliberately there it
lets the cops know that this is not an
actual gun they got a call the police
got a call that there was somebody who's
running around the park with an actual
gun they got there and there was
somebody who's running around the park
with what appeared to be an actual gun
and didn't stop and put down the gun
when told to do so that doesn't mean the
shoot was good but you try and say that
that is a racist murder based solely on
the race of the 12 year old child Tamir
rice to lump all these things together
right those are disputed cases here's an
undisputed case the case of Walter Scott
he never gets mentioned in this litany
it's truly amazing
we'll see this a little bit later when
he gets in
call Hannon Jones's awful piece on
reparations the the attempt to lump all
these cases together they have very very
different fact patterns and then they
ignore the one most clear-cut racist
case why because what happened in that
case what happened a police officer wins
jail for murder so they won't talk about
that case because in a case where the
system were they won't talk about it
because if the system works he can't
indict the system so instead you have to
pick a case with a with a variegated
fact pattern with a difficult fact
pattern and then you suggest the system
didn't work because in this case in this
case the system is really shown not the
Walter Scott case we have a clear-cut
case where a black man is running away
from a police officer unarmed the
officer shoots him in the back and then
tries to plant a gun on him
the officer ends up in jail I did as he
should for murder right that Walter
Scott it's amazing if you ever want to
know about the the bad faith of people
who make a lot of these arguments and
notice that in the litany of victims of
white police violence Walter Scott never
gets mentioned he never gets mentioned
it's truly an incredible thing and you
have to wonder why and you really don't
have to wonder why because it's never
about the solutions it's never about
fixing the problem it is always about
inviting the system generally speaking
so senator Mitch McConnell he went on
the floor yesterday and he said listen
you guys were the ones who were like put
a bill on the floor and they were like
okay we'll put a bill on the floor then
you refused to even allow us to amend
the bill or debate the bill so it seems
to me that you're not super focused on
solutions here guys for weeks Democratic
leader has bustard that the Senate
simply had to address this issue before
July 4th well that's what the vote this
morning is about are you beginning to
see how this game works two weeks ago it
was implied the Senate would have blood
on our hands if we didn't take up police
reform now Democrats say senator Scott
and 48 other senators have blood on our
hands because we are trying to take up
police reform
correct correct by the way that Pelosi
bill is going nowhere you know why it's
not going anywhere it's not going
anywhere because Pelosi is not allowing
any amendments to be brought Nancy
Pelosi sees committee is not allowing
any coming amendments to be brought on
the Democrats police reform bill which
means it's going absolutely nowhere the
rule provides for four hours of debate a
bill no amendments and and then a
straight vote so do you think that bill
is going anywhere the Republicans were
offering amendments and the Democrats
anyway this is not about solutions it
simply is not about solutions I'll get
some more of this in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
with everything going on right now a lot
of people are asking if it's even
possible to buy life insurance at all
the short answer is sure you can buy
life insurance during the pandemic in
fact a lot of people are doing so as an
insurance marketplace policy genius is
in contact with the life insurance
companies on their platform every day
they're keeping track of all the changes
in the market so you don't have to which
means they can get you covered quickly
and for the best price here is how it
works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
you can find your best price this
doesn't just save a lot of legwork you
could say 1500 bucks or more every year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies I mean you're saving
yourself a ton of time and a ton of
money once you apply the policy genius
team handles all the paperwork and the
red tape for free so if you had any
speed bumps during the application
process they will be there to take care
of everything life insurance it's a
moral obligation if you have a family
and people who are reliant on your
income go check out policy genius.com
right now if you're one of the many
people looking to buy life insurance
right now but you're not sure where to
start head on over to policy genius.com
again that's policy genius com policy
genius we'll find you the best rate
handle the process completely they'll
get you and your family protected
hopefully they'll give you one less
thing to worry about go check them out
right now at policy genius.com that is
policy genius dot speaking of the system
working right and so it will stop being
in the news the automat Arbour a case
that case in in georgia a georgia grand
jury has just indicted three suspects in
the off Matar berry case that was the
case of the black guy who was jogging
through the neighborhood after
trespassing on an open on an open
construction site which is not an excuse
to try and roadblock somebody and then
confront them with a shotgun which is
exactly what happened and our burry ends
up being being murdered according to the
according to the prosecutors the alleged
vigilante style murder barber by three
white men who mistook him for a burglar
ignited nationwide outrage but not as
much a nationwide outrage as George
Floyd you'll notice right then the
George Floyd case is much more paid
attention to
why because I suppose the idea is that
in this case the system worked so
whenever the system works the media pay
less attention to it that's the way this
works when the system works the media
pay less attention to it immediate have
an interest in driving a particular
narrative that
that's just the reality the media are
pushing a particular narrative that
America does not care about black men
and particularly doesn't care about
black men who are killed but does not
care about racism in general America
just doesn't care about racism this this
narrative is so important his narrative
is so important in the media that even
instances of non racism are portrayed as
continuing grievances about racism it's
a perfect example Bubba Wallace
yesterday finally admitted oh yeah by
the way that wasn't a news remember that
home last car was a newson his garage
and then Bubba Wallace went on national
TV and he said no it was a straight-up
news like nope dude that was not a
straight-up news that was not a news it
was not a news it was a it was a hand
pull it wasn't even a slipknot right it
was it was a it was a hand pull on a on
a garage door and Bubba Wallace like
nuts a straight-up noose and the entire
left started mimicking this notion that
we should still worry about this as a
racist incident even after it has been
debunked well finally Bubba Wallace puts
out a good statement which he should
have put out in the first place he says
it's been an emotional few days first
off I want to say how relieved I am the
investigation revealed this wasn't what
we feared it was I want to thank my team
NASCAR and the FBI for acting swiftly
and treating this as a real threat I
think will gladly take a little
embarrassment over what the alternatives
could have been make no mistake that
some will try it should not detract from
the show of unity we had on Monday and
the progress we've made as a sport to be
more welcoming for all okay that that's
the same you should been put out in the
first place because soon as this story
was debunked Essure said it's pretty
amazing that the entire NASCAR came
around me when we even thought that this
was happening right that's a sign of
racial progress ha but the New York
Times will not allow that here is the
New York Times headline Talladega news
incident puts a spotlight on NASCAR's
troubles with racism oh so a thing that
didn't happen highlights NASCAR's
troubles with racism so the things
debunked by the FBI and you're still
going with the story that this
highlights NASCAR's troubles with racism
the entire motor team over at Talladega
all the drivers all the pit crews Marsh
with Bubba Wallace to the front of
Talladega over an incident that didn't
happen to fight supposed racism and your
headline at the New York Times is
Talladega noose incidents puts a
spotlight on NASCAR's troubles with
racism of course that has to be your
headline because if you actually put the
fats in the headline non noose incident
with significant overreaction
against racism against the race
incident that did not occur put
spotlight on recently it makes no sense
the minute the facts are known this
story makes no sense but it doesn't
matter
Juliet Makura and Alan Blinder talk
about it talk about this situations in
the national turmoil of a race and
serial injustice has complicated both
Wallace's reaction and the public's
response to the FBI's findings with the
government's investigation closed and no
charges filed Wallace has found himself
all but forced to defend himself from
baseless speculation that he or his
supporters staged the incident to garner
publicity all but forced to defend
himself really like force who's forcing
him like seriously who well NASCAR
characterized the noose as a pull robe
for a garage door that was fashioned
like a news some people insisted the
news was just a rope with a handle and
that Wallace and stock-car racing
executives had overreacted well it
literally was a pull cord on a garage so
yeah I'm gonna go with they overreacted
by calling it a news but according to
the New York Times the narrative must
never die and their ovens never die even
situations that don't happen are
indicators of racism by the way I fully
predicted that I fully predicted that I
tweeted yesterday at the New York Times
the next day would run with the story
about how garage door pull handles have
a long racist history in the United
States I mean this stuff is is wild and
crazy and there are consequences to it
there are consequences to it okay it
leads to full-on foolishness so the most
foolish article of the day again comes
courtesy of it in the New York Times
it's called the Minneapolis neighborhood
vowed to check its privilege it's
already being tested okay this is all
about how again white people are
refusing to acknowledge their white
privilege but what's hilarious about the
article is it really demonstrates how
when you are initiated into the white
woke leftist thought complex it's
unsustainable in idiotic it's truly
incredible so there are a few different
stories that are that are told here so
the let me read some of this to you when
sherry Albers moved three decades ago
into Powderhorn Park a tree-lined
Minneapolis neighborhood known as a
havens leftist activist and bohemian
artists like herself she wants work
sprucing it up she'd become a block club
leader organizing her mostly white
neighbors to bring in playgrounds and
help tackle long-standing issues with
crimes on many nights she banged on car
windows of men when it comes to solicit
prostitutes outside her door she said
she kept meticulous notes when dozens of
men would gather in a circle for gang
meetings in the park across from her
house after each episode she called the
police but times have changed
after the death of George Floyd at the
hands of police mrs. Albers who is white
and many of her progressive neighbors
have valid to avoid calling law
enforcement into their community doing
so they believed would add to the pain
the black residents of Minneapolis were
feeling and could put them in danger
okay so when you draw their narrative
the police are all endemically racist
and not only that you are implicated in
the racism if you call the cops when you
see a crime people stop calling the cops
and they see a crime what do you think
happens to the crime rates you think
they go down anything to go up if you're
not a of course they go up so
here's what the New York Times reports
already that commitment is being
challenged
two weeks ago dozens of multicolored
tents appeared in the neighborhood park
they were brought by homeless people
were displaced during the unrest that
gripped the city the multi racial group
of roughly 300 new residents seems to
grow larger and more entrenched every
day they do laundry listen to music and
strategize about how to find permanent
housing
some are hem are hampered by mental
illness addiction or both their presence
has drawn heavy car traffic into the
neighborhood some from drug dealers at
least two residents have overdosed in
the encampment and had to be taken away
in ambulances the influx of outsiders
has kept miss Albers awake at night
though it is unlikely to happen she has
had visions of people from the tent camp
forcing their way into her home she
imagines using a baseball bat to defend
herself not being able to call the
police as she has done for decades has
shaken her I am afraid she said I know
my neighbors are around and I'm not
feeling grounded in my city at all
anything could happen
she's just not gonna call the cops
anymore and then her neighborhood is
being taken over by people who are
overdosing in the park so things are
going great guys really well done the
consequences of the narrative being
promulgated at the expense of the facts
there are real-world consequences to
this sort of stuff that really are
bringing more examples of this in just a
second then we'll get to the 16:19
editor Nicola Hannon Jones doing her
best bury one Tanya he see Coates
impersonation calling for reparations
and doing what she does best ignoring
facts in the process I mean she she
really is she's truly awful at her job
but she's she's won a Pulitzer so I
guess we're done here we'll get to that
in just a second first let's talk about
the fact that if you've been listening
to the show for a while you've heard me
talk about my helix mattress right helix
sleep it's fantastic my mattress is
great well good news helix has now gone
beyond the bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
it's called all form they're making
premium customizable sofas and chairs
ship directly to your door so what makes
it off
so a really cool well for starters it's
the easiest way you can customize the
sofa using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric and it's
bills pay its spills stain scratch
resistant the sofa color color of the
legs of the size shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home I just got
an offer for him sofa it was really easy
to assemble I mean it took like no time
at all and it is just it's gorgeous it
is clean it is stain resistant which I
have kids it's why I need stain
resistant furniture it is it is durable
it's great I picked out the three seat
sofa with chase in the sand color with
an espresso legs and it's beautiful it
really does add to my home in a serious
way if getting a so fun without trying
it in the store sounds a little risky
don't worry you got a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep it more than
three months and if you don't love it
they will pick it up for free and give
you a full refund they also have a
forever warranty literally forever to
find your perfect so if I check out all
forum comm slash pen and all forum is
offering 20% off all orders for my
listeners at all forum comm slash beds
that is a great deal 20% off all orders
just for my listeners all form a ll fo
RM comm slash man go check them out the
sofas fantastic and again you get a
variety of different options colors it's
it's it's durable it's great go check it
out right now okay so back to these this
New York Times piece so the New York
Times has this entire piece about white
oak liberals and feel bad calling the
cops when they see a crime I'm not being
judgmental said Kerry nightshade 44 who
explained she no longer felt comfortable
letting her children 12 and 9 playing
the part by themselves it's not personal
it's just not safe well as we learned
from Robyn D'Angelo this means she's a
racist on Friday she sat in a shared
backyard with four other women who live
in neighboring houses the women four of
whom are white had called a meeting to
vent about the camp
Angelina Ross slick burst into tears
explaining she'd spent the past four
years fleeing unstable housing
conditions and was struggling more than
she cared to admit with the chaos the
camp had brought into the neighborhood
Linea Borden said she had stopped
walking her dogs from the park because
she was tired of being catcalled my
emotions change over 30 seconds said
shreya Hauser who's part Native American
well that means that she's immune she
can't be racist obviously the women
agreed to let any property damage
including to their own homes go ignored
and to request a block party permit from
the city to limit car traffic rather
than turn to law enforcement if they saw
anyone in physical danger their results
called the American Indian Movement a
national organization created in 1968 to
address Native American grievances such
as police brutality which had been
policing
own community locally for years but some
people in the neighborhood have already
found their best-laid plans to avoid
calling the police harder to execute
than they had imagined because here's
the deal if you commit a crime and
you're a person of color well then it is
racist to call the police on you
people are not held to the same standard
like don't commit crimes in the United
States anymore if you have a particular
if you have a particular history as a
member of a victimized racial group then
apparently you are immune to the law
because if you call the police the
police might come and be very mean the
police might come and they might be
racist based on which evidence the
evidence that stuff last Thursday night
joseph menn kovitch found a black man
wearing a hospital bracelet passed out
in the elevator of his apartment
building to blast away from the park man
kovitch was white quickly phoned a
community activist but she did not pick
up he felt he had no choice but to call
9-1-1 so he did but requesting an
ambulance only not the police ultimately
a white police officer arrived at the
scene he also checked the situation out
briefly and then returned to his squad
car it didn't resolve the way I hope mr.
man kovitch said all they did was offer
to bring him back to the hospital he
refused so they kicked him out on a
rainy night what the hell else were they
supposed to do so if they if they shoved
him into the squad car and taken him to
the hospital because he obviously needed
to be in a hospital then he would have
claimed they were responsible for police
brutality I'm sorry this is ridiculous
crap and these people are insane and
self parodic it's it's this is this is
it's just it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous to the extent that illegal
activity is going on in the park Toby
Miller who is 34 doesn't I blame the
tent residents my feeling around it is
those are symptoms of systemic
oppression and that's not on them all
personal responsibility is gone you can
commit any crime you want because
systemic oppression systemic oppression
good stuff guys really really solid
stuff on a recent afternoon Sarah Kenyon
Diane Columba or both white were speed
walking behind their toddler sons
through the park leading up to the camp
miss Kenney had been volunteering there
a few times a week she said the
experience had challenged her to
consider not only the safety of thrown
family which has a comfortable home and
locked doors to retreat behind but also
that of people living outside without
protection miss Columbo agreed
some people have color in the
neighborhood however said they were
skeptical the community would allow the
encampment to stay this thing is
probably gonna last two or three weeks
it is Ochoa a Mexican a Native American
father who is walking through the park
with his three children yeah you think
okay here's the
Michell Erickson's fingers began tiling
9-1-1 last week before he had a chance
to even consider alternatives when two
black teenagers who looked to be 15 at
most cornered him outside his home a
block away from the park one of the boys
pointed a gun at mr. Erickson's chest
demanding his car keys flustered mr.
erikson hands it over a set but it
turned out to be the house keys the
teenagers got frustrated and ran off and
stole a different car down the street
mr. erikson said later he would not
cooperate with the prosecutors in the
case against the boys after the
altercation he realized that that if
there was anything he wanted it was to
offer them help but he still felt it had
been right to call the authorities
because there was a gun involved two
days after an initial conversation his
position had evolved and thinking more
about it he wrote in a text message
I regret calling the police it was my
instinct but I wish it hadn't been I put
those boys in danger of death by calling
the cops what about the fact the boys
had put his life in danger quote yeah I
know and yeah it was scary but the cops
didn't really have much to add after I
called them I haven't been forced to
think like this before so I would have
lost my car so what at least no one
would have been killed okay you're
talking about the end of civil society
here all you're talking about is the end
of civil society you cannot hold people
to the basic standards of acting like a
human being like oh I don't know don't
point your gun at somebody's chest and
threaten to shoot them if they don't let
you steal their car okay but you can't
call the cops as you call the cops
you're a racist does anybody think any
of this is sustainable does anybody
think any of this is sustainable of
course none of this is sustainable the
idea that personal responsibility has
disappeared into the vast ether of
systemic oppression is so dangerous for
any society again if you want to point
to a system that needs to be changed and
changed the system if you want to point
to a racist person doing a racist thing
then let's all fight that together but
don't give me I can't call the cops when
someone points a gun at my chest and
steals my car that's nuts
that's perfectly insane on every level
but again maybe the goal here is not
solutions we go right back to the
beginning maybe the goal here is not
solutions because this ain't a solution
maybe the goal here is just a narrative
and the narrative ends with the idea
that there is a vast group of ODE in the
United States and a vast group of a wing
in the United States and you can tell
who is owed and who is owing simply by
dint of skin colour which seems fairly
racist to me it seems fairly racist to
me that you refuse to take into account
any of the personal decision-making
involved in being a human being
personal agents he disappears completely
we are all
simply the product of systems that's all
we are and this presumably is why you
end up with essays like the giant essay
in the New York Times magazine what is
owed a suggestion that slavery
reparations are Odin this will fix all
problems now listen you can make the
case for slavery reparations if the idea
is that a wrong has been done and it
needs to be repaired typically you have
to link the wrong that has been done to
a person and to the person who has been
wronged like if I god forbid my father
hit somebody with his car it would not
be on me to pay that person's grandson
right that's not the way that justice
works I just put that out front the
notion of racial reparations or
Holocaust reparations or any reparations
is that the people who are responsible
for the sin have to pay the people who
are responsible people who are
victimized by the sin but they actually
have to been victimized it can't just
have been it's something bad happened to
my grandfather and that has historical
after-effects because otherwise there is
no there's no limiting principle there
the history of the world is replete with
groups victimizing one another there is
literally no end to that particular
logic but the real logic of slavery
reparations is again the logic that
systemic oppression is great rationale
for all disparities in American society
and the and the evidence that is offered
to prove this particularly vulnerable
case is usually pretty skimpy and it
usually relies on extraordinarily broad
claims put in in particularly passionate
language that is it that is why the the
cases on reparations are typically being
written not by economists on how this
will help black Americans they're
typically being written by people who
are really bad at history like Nicole
Hannah Jones or by people who are most
famous for their for their prose
craftsmanship like Tallahassee thuds hey
that's we'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you know your house right now oh
that's okay it's okay but you're looking
around you think I just refurbished this
place why doesn't it look better the
answer is you didn't look at your blinds
did you you didn't look at your blinds
now I know it sounds like not a big
thing it actually is great window
coverings can really make a home not
everyone has the means to do a full
renovation but there are some small
changes you can make to help improve
your home thanks to our friends over at
blinds.com they make it really simple to
shop top-quality blinds shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering and free shipping window
treatments are simple projects you can
do that really benefits the feel of your
home experts say not getting enough
can increase levels of stress hormones
in your body so you want to have the
proper trades you want to make sure you
have all the proper window coverings
consider some light filtering window
treatments roller shades cellular shades
and more to transform your home into
even more of a sanctuary if you're
nervous about doing it yourself there
really is no reason to be lines calm and
saw millions of homeowners through the
process with free online design help
plus they guarantee the perfect fit so
if you screw it up they'll do it for you
go to blinds.com to see how you can
reimagine the look of your home today
rules and restrictions may apply go
check them out right now I've used
blinds commet myself that greatly
enhanced the appeal of my home and it's
not gonna cost you a fortune and it's
really really easy go check them out
right now at blinds.com ready in just a
second we're gonna get to Nicola Hannah
Jones push it the author of the 1619
project calling for slavery reparations
what she's really attempting to do could
slay 'very reparations are not going to
happen
realistically speaking they're not going
to happen because it'd be nearly
impossible to administer but what she's
really doing is trying to suggest that
all disparities in American society
should be attributed to the system as a
whole so the system needs to be torn
down which is a very Marxist point of
view on how the US should work we'll get
to that we'll also get to the spikes
that are happening around the country on
Kogut 19 which are very dangerous we'll
get to that as well first if you're not
already a daily wear member should
consider getting a readers past a daily
wire.com that's a great value for only
three bucks a month when you sign up you
get that first month for only 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials like my newest editorial the
only good people in history live right
now all about the protesters and people
tearing down statutes because they're
the only good people who have ever lived
you can go check that out right now if
you haven't checked out the readers past
already head on over to daily wear comm
and sign up for just one dollar sign
just a buck you can make that happen
daily wire.com go subscribe but right
now you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so Nicole head and Jones is
pushing forward need the author of the
1619 project who has said that she is
happy if they call it the 1619 riots
what's been going on around the country
she has a piece in The New York Times
Magazine suggesting that it's time for
racial reparations what the piece is
really about the call for racial
reparations is rarely a call for a
specific policy because it turns out
what what amount of money would be
sufficient to repair for slavery it
technically ended in 1865 what what
amount of what amounts of money would be
sufficient to answer for Jim Crow how
would you calculate that amount
especially we are now talking nearly 60
years after the fact we're talking about
the grandchildren of the people who were
subjected to Jim Crow how exactly would
you would you measure that Nicole Hannah
Jones doesn't bother with any of that
because again the goal of the the case
for slavery reparations and for racial
reparation the the goal is to attribute
all disparity all of it to
discrimination because America is
endemically evil it's it's it's just an
extension of the 1619 project mentality
now in order to get to this answer you
have to play a bunch of of tricks
linguistic tricks historical tricks a
factual tricks and Nicole Hannah Jones
is certainly not above any of that she
says it has been more than 150 years
since the white planter class last
called up slave patrols and deputized
every white citizens to stop question
and subdue any black person who came
across their paths in order to control
and surveillance to submit to their
enslavement has been a hundred and fifty
years since white Americans couldn't
force slave laws that said white people
acting in the interest of the planter
class would not be punished for killing
a black person those laws morphed into
the Black Codes passed by white southern
politicians at the end of the Civil War
to criminalize behaviors like not having
a job those Black Codes were struck down
and altered over the course of decades
eventually transmuted into
stop-and-frisk broken windows and of
course qualified immunity okay that is
just such sheer that it's just such a
sheer lie that the basic idea that slave
patrols morphed into stop and frisk that
is nuts that is nuts okay but this is
the linguistic trick again America has
not changed the Mareth has just
transmuted America has not gotten any
better America's just gotten more subtle
racism never went away
racism is in fact there and it is racism
that is the driving indicator of
inequality between white and lab between
white and black that is that is the
driving factor in American life which
again is this about solutions the answer
is of course it's not about solutions
you could cut a check to everybody in
America today who is black and it would
not alleviate either number one the
historical the historical wrongs that
were done it would not alleviate that at
all right all those historical wrongs
would still exist and also it would
probably not alleviate and when I say
probably I mean almost indubitably would
not fix all of the gaps between white
and black in the United States absent
changes in other factors absent like the
fact is that the drivers of the income
gap for example are things like dropout
rates in schools inability to get a good
education from schools single motherhood
rent these things do matter but
according to Nicole Hannah Jones they
don't matter whatsoever like at all I
don't I don't just mean she says they
don't matter enough I mean she literally
says in the essay they do not matter at
all
confounding factors do not matter there
is a direct quote in this in this piece
here's the direct quote in this piece
ready to summarize none of the actions
we are told black people must take if
they want to lift themselves out of
poverty and gain financial stability not
marrying not getting educated not saving
more not owning a home can mitigate 400
years of racialized plundering none of
those and so all personal responsibility
has been lifted every inequality in
American life is attributable to slavery
and by the way when you say 400 years of
racialized plundering to again equate
today to get to 400 years of racialized
plunder and you have to go 1619 to 2019
right - to say that there has been no
mitigation whatsoever of racialized
plundering in the United States you know
between full-on slavery at the end of
slavery and Jim Crow and the end of Jim
Crow is to be historically lying which
is what of course she's very good at
she's very good at this and all of this
is designed not to create solutions is
not designed to help black Americans all
it is designed to do is tear down the
system about our ears and to suggest
that the system itself the system of
individualism the system of meritocracy
is inherently flawed inherently biased I
promise you Cole Hannah Jones if it
checks got signed tomorrow
Nicole Hannah Jones the next day would
explain that the checks were
insufficient because all remaining
inequalities after the writing of the
checks would still be the result of
systemic American racism by the way
Donaghy C codes in his own
on the case for reparations basically
says this I mean he says it's straight
out in his piece
sure slavery reparations might not
actually fix anything but at least we'll
have done it okay that is not a case for
slavery reparations especially when you
are talking about doing an injustice
today to people who live on behalf of
people who lived three generations ago
minimum okay well on behalf of our
grandparents this is not about solutions
now speaking of thank people who are not
about solutions let's let's move on to
Cove in nineteen so it is fairly obvious
at this point that Cove in nineteen
there are only a few things that we can
do one there are a few treatments that
we have attempted in hospitals they've
had some mitigating effect there's a
pretty common steroid apparently that
has a mitigating effect on on people who
are in fairly serious conditions who
require oxygen or who require
ventilators we know that if you protect
nursing homes and you test everybody
going in now you can prevent the death
of huge swathes of citizens we learned
that from Andrew Cuomo who didn't we
know that masks can help prevent
transmission of the thing and the
universal masking in places like Hong
Kong and South Korea and Japan has been
fairly successful at preventing the
transmission of these disease vectors
with all of that said there is no
solution to the virus right now and
there's not going to be a solution for
several months and this is happening
across the country it's the media been
focusing almost solely on Florida and
Texas Florida Texas Arizona right those
are that's the triumvirate Florida Texas
Arizona what do all those places have in
common they're all governed by
Republicans right so Ducey in Arizona
and Greg Abbott in Texas and around to
Santos in Florida these are of course
the hotspots these are of course the
worst places there are the very very bad
places and California is getting crushed
right now California is just getting
wrecked in the the virus cases in
California are up extraordinarily
heavily they're up so heavily the
Disneyland just too late its reopening
Disneyland which was supposed to open on
July 17th they said we're not gonna open
at all the state of California said the
company has now indicated it will not
issue theme-park reopening guidelines
until sometime after July 4th given the
time required for us to bring thousands
of cast members back to work and restart
our business we have no choice but to
delay the reopening of our theme parks
and resort hotels until we receive
approval from government officials
there's been a spike in LA County LA
County now officially has more cases
than any other county in Amer
hospitalization rates are not as high as
feared but obviously those
hospitalization rates could rise fairly
dramatically because hospitalization is
a trailing indicator basically there's
three steps you get diagnosed and then
it might take a few days until you have
to go to the hospital you might not have
to go and then after that a few days
until you get to the ICU so the deaths
are the biggest trailing indicator so
deaths are low right now that's because
we're actually looking at stats from two
weeks ago
if hospitalizations are low right now
we're actually looking at stats from one
week ago we're gonna have to wait a week
to see where we are in terms of
hospitalizations in two weeks in terms
of deaths according to ABC News as
coronavirus cases continue to climb
across the country a new forecast from
the CDC says the US could soon see
150,000 fatalities currently we have at
least one hundred and twenty-two
thousand fatalities with 2.3 million to
two point three eight million confirmed
cases according to data from Johns
Hopkins University dozens of Secret
Service agents are now in self
quarantine after president Trump's rally
in Tulsa over the weekend a source
familiar with the matter told ABC News a
number of Secret Service personnel who
are self quarantine is in the low dozens
because basically they were in public
and a lot of people were not wearing
masks apparently they're a bunch of
people who are sick already Disneyland
as I mentioned delayed reopening Nevada
the state of Nevada has now mandated
that everybody in the state worth masks
or facial coverings in order to stop the
spread of Kovan 19 which is correct
Texas is offering local authorities the
ability to mandate mask wearing the same
thing is happening in in Florida in
California over 19 cases saw a stunning
69 percent jump in just two days
according to governor Gavin Newsom
California reported 4230 new cases on
Sunday on Monday 5,000 new cases on
Tuesday 71 hundred new cases as the
state increases testing residents should
anticipate more of an increase in the
positivity rate said the governor
hospitalization numbers have increased
thirty percent of ICU capacity statewide
is being used right now obviously the
spike is what people fear la has over
eighty eight thousand five hundred
residents diagnosed with Kovan 19
followed by eighty seven thousand seven
hundred cases in Cook County Illinois
which is Chicago and 64 thousand cases
in Queens in New York City in comparison
the entire state of Florida right you've
only heard about Florida the entire
state of Florida had one hundred and
nine thousand cases so LA County is
about 10 million residents Florida has
21 point 4
million residents Florida has about
12,000 20,000 well 11,000 cases more
than the entire County of Los Angeles in
in LA which goes to show you that well
well Florida is getting hit I mean
Florida is getting hit they have a 16%
positivity rate out of the tests
conducted on Tuesday thirty six thousand
three hundred tests conducted on Tuesday
this is not a mere Florida problem this
is an everywhere problem now it's
obviously in every where problem right
now according to Axios every single
state in the US with the exception of
North Dakota and South Dakota and
Alabama Indiana New Jersey Maryland New
York New Hampshire and Maine as well as
DC every single one of those areas has
seen every other state has seen either a
keeping steady or a vast increase in the
number of koba 19 cases particularly
steep increases like an over 50%
increase in combination cases in states
like Washington Idaho Montana Michigan
Oklahoma Texas Florida and Arizona
according to Axios the US today is
getting closer to the worst case
scenario envisioned in the spring a
nationwide crisis made worse by a vacuum
of political leadership threatening to
overwhelm hospitals and spread out of
control they say this is the grimmest
map in the eight weeks since Axios began
tracking the change in new cases in
every state alternatively it is very
difficult to keep something under
control
as soon as people leave their homes okay
as soon as people leave their and by the
way mass protests it turns out they did
not immunize you to to cope in nineteen
CNN yesterday I had this ridiculous
piece where they suggested that
protesting did not spread the virus and
then what the actual study said was
protesting may have been drowned out by
the fact that so many people stayed home
so in other words everyone got curfew
and the people who were curfew didn't
get cove in nineteen but people at the
protest may well have been getting the
virus which of course they will then
bring home and give to mom and dad and
grandma and grandpa so you know this is
this is dire stuff for sure and we are
seeing that even in countries like
germany the there's been a bit of a
resurgence in kovat 19 the the our rate
the reproduction rate is going up in in
in germany we've seen that the the rates
are are going up around the world really
there's a coronavirus resurgence
apparently that has been
in South Korea as well so it's not just
the United States everybody's sort of
pretending that this is just the US it
is not just the US obviously so are
there any real solutions to this well
there really is only one and that is
personal responsibility Marco Rubio
yesterday senator from Florida he said
listen just put on the stupid mask just
put it on like seriously let's let's
keep this thing tamp down you want to go
back to work you wanna have a good time
you don't have to wear a mask when
you're at the beach you're far away from
other people or when you're eating
outdoors away from other people but if
you're in an enclosed area in an in
condition in an air-conditioned room
wear a mask it's correct about this
however unfortunately the world is
filled with stupid people I do want to
point out that again the media coverage
here is pretty astonishing so LA County
has seen as I say almost as many cases
in the entire state of Florida
with about half the population CNN
however is focused laser-like in on
crazy people in Florida so that there
are new restrictions in miami-dade and
Palm Beach County and a bunch of people
went to sort of the local Parks and Rec
board meeting and decided to yell at the
board that had mandated mask-wearing as
there's a new rule in Palm Beach County
as well as Miami Dade that when you are
in the indoor crowded area you need to
wear a mask so CNN covered this Florida
Town Hall the real question here is why
see and uncovered it not that there are
crazy people if you've ever been to a
public event where people speak out to
like their local boards the only people
who have time and energy to do this sort
of stuff are exactly the sort of people
you would not want in control of policy
nonetheless it made for some colorful TV
there was some crazy people yelling at
this board that was mandating mask
wearing you literally cannot mandate
somebody to wear a mask knowing that
that mask is killing people every single
one of you that are obeying the devil's
laws are going to be arrested and you
doctor are going to be arrested for
crimes against humanity problem with
humanity today is ignorance arrogance
and apathy keep taking the road of least
resistant keep listening to the TV brain
watching you from birth and they want to
throw God's wonderful breathing system
out the door you're all turning your
backs on it okay okay
so I think probably those people should
not control our public policy just gonna
put that out there we probably shouldn't
put that out there those those people
are not but again the point
is that CNN will cover that they're not
gonna go down to LA and find the crazies
who go to the local town hall meetings
they'll only do it in Florida because
Florida man right that's that's that's
the whole that's the whole goal here hey
by the way mentioned worth mentioning
the Democrats are now planning a virtual
convention so everybody is sort of
expecting this'll last until the fall I
believe Washington DC has already
declared they may not reopen schools so
if you thought that this was going to
end any time soon wrong you were
unfortunately as always there are not a
lot of great solutions the only solution
be personally responsible protect
yourself if you're older if you are
younger wear a mask to protect the
elderly and the vulnerable around you
it's a pain in the butt
I don't like doing it either nobody
likes doing it but be a responsible
human being and make sure that this
thing does not spread out of control
okay we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of content a lot
more to talk about including Michael
Flynn being released an appeals court
has now ordered the release of Michael
Flynn we'll get to that a little bit
later on in the day otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SCI events audio is mixed by Mike
foramina hair and makeup is by Anika
Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Klavan show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]